ragazzi basta fare il Mercante ma ho
voluto sfruttare l'ultimo momento che ho
disponibile per farlo perché questo è
l'ultimo episodio di Resident Evil for
remake sono vestito diversamente sono
tutto soddisfatto Tra l'altro perché ho
appena finito di montare quest'ultima
puntata Scusate la premessa un po' più
lunga del solito e registro questo pezzo
alla fine del del montaggio dell'ultimo
episodio mi sono fatto un culo quadro
ragazzi a montare tutto ve lo assicuro
perché li ho montati tutti io perché
Resident Evil 4 per me ragazzi è uno dei
giochi horror migliori che esistano
quando hanno annunciato il remake ero in
iPad 1000 l'ho giocato tutto e l'ho
montato tutto quindi è come se l'avessi
giocato due volte e non mi sono mai
annoiato mezzo secondo è una delle più
belle serie sul mio canale secondo me io
lo dico all'alba dei dieci anni su
YouTube Lo gli abbiamo già fatti questa
è stata una delle migliori serie sul
canale nonostante Ormai non ci sia più
quella quella hype che c'era una volta
sui Gameplay io sono contento di averlo
fatto e che questo sia ancora il mio
lavoro perché per me è una passione è
avervi portato questo Gameplay completo
mi fa capire che mi piace ancora
tantissimo fare quello che faccio e
grazie a voi che continuate a sostenermi
un bacio a tutti Vi voglio bene e
godetevi quest'ultimo episodio di questo
capolavoro Resident Evil forum Let's go
era stato lui l'ha appiccicarci con le
merde degli insetti Vabbè
occhiali setacci
glia che male Basta dove cazzo devo
colpire questi qua no mi fanno malissimo
ragazzi Attenzione questi qua sono più
forti degli altri Minchia non ha seccato
Porca [__] Vabbè ormai mi dispiace
Vediamo se ma non c'è il Mercante qua e
dove cazzo è
Esatto È quello che pensava anch'io
Bravo Lion
no eh che mi scendono quegli stronzi lì
che non ho più il coso termico ci manca
solo Guarda ti ho dato per scontato che
non ci siano più pensavo ci fosse il
Mercante ma anche perché non ha senso e
Vamos
Vediamo che succede ma che cos'è che c'è
altra roba Oh che cazzo fai Non è vero
non è vero che c'è ancora questo
Non è vero che c'è ancora questo ma non
ho colpito tre
due parassiti con Che cazzo è ho beccato
due parassiti con una con un colpo solo
vai
No
è Figurati se lo becco una volta OH
Mannaggia a merda Sei mia solita sfiga
di merda Ok
vediamo se riesco a colpirlo no attento
e quando torno fanno male sti cosi
Ok Diamante giallo Va bene dai ma devo
fare è sempre a tempo sta roba
cioè limite se devono esserci mutanti
pure di qua Ok perfetto
Eccolo lo zio Eccolo qua mi sei mancato
Eh Sinceramente sei mancato ah vediamo
se c'è qualcosa in giro qua non c'è un
cazzo il poligono di tiro Sì sì ha
voglia Allora vivendo un po' di roba io
il coltello da combattimento ragazzi lo
venderei Ma perché ormai ho il coltello
d'assalto che cazzo me ne faccio
questo vai di paragone questo riparo ok
e a sto punto Mi prenderei lo Striker
perché mi sa di più
cazzuto e vediamo se riesco a
potenziarlo un pochettino almeno lo
Striker raga dai Comunque tre armi
potenziate quasi al massimo quindi va
bene così Let's go my boys
sempre dal nulla sto qua
Madonna Non vedo l'ora di affrontare il
boss finale non so neanche cosa possa
uscire fuori perché ho una Magnum super
carica cioè teoricamente gli svuoto
tutto il caricatore In The Face poi non
lo so Uh Salve anzi Guarda facciamo così
No non facciamo
Ok il prossimo
Ok Uh l'erbetta verde Attenzione che c'è
qualcuno lo lanciarazzi Sti figli di
[__]
morto No Meno male che c'è quello scarso
che non vi sta colpendo a destra Ok
chiami un attimo No non mi ha fatto
niente
Potete smetterla di spararmi dall'alto
mi date fastidio
se voglia magnarmi cosa che ha detto
entra entra veloce Oddio cioè People Eh
ciao
Devo passare di qua passo di qua rascio
un attimo perché lì c'è un coso che
esplode bene
molto bene ok Qua c'è una madonna di
gente mi hanno tirato un coso in faccia
Va bene perfetto Tutto normale
ragazzi miglior giocata del da quando ho
iniziato a giocare perché veramente
troppo forte sta pistolina stupida Cioè
veramente una pistolina ha fatto tutta
la differenza in tutto il gameplay
ok
a posto Salve
c'è ancora gente Cioè ragazzi Sento
rumori strani
che non mi stanno piacendo però non vedo
niente Eccolo no amiche con l'arma e con
l'arma
Porca [__] Non è che non mi ha preso
Ok perfetto perfetto perfetto vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vola
vola vola vola vola vola vola vola vola
vola vola vola vola vola vola vola no
che male non mi ha preso Che culo
comunque di nuovo L'armatura è andata a
[__] ragazzi sul finale di gioco
l'armatura non dura neanche un secondo
fuori uno
merda
Ok Magnum
perfetto vai ok
È morto il mais
questi qua ho capito come buttarli giù
subito
bravo Ci hai provato e ci sei anche
riuscito Bravo Sono sceso otto prima
farlo così perché non riuscivo a
colpirlo bene sono tutti seccati Ci ho
messo una vita e mezza da parte
veramente E ovviamente sul finale di
gioco È tutto difficile ma porca [__] è
difficilissimo siamo arrivati al coso
cioè teoricamente ce l'abbiamo fatta non
c'è più niente
vediamo
non è che me la sono tirata di nuovo Eh
forse sì Vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua si
apre si apre già quindi a posto bello
se qui Ashley Eh che ne so dove è andata
cazzo ne so io vado a casa seguila Eh
boh Eccola posso sparare qua
sto casino
sì
ragazzi
Prevedo casini qua dentro sembra sembra
la stanza di una boss Fight di Elder
Ring questa
voglio solo condividere il mio dono Con
quanti più possibile ma perché non ti
fai i cazzi tuoi
vedi noi tutti siamo connessi tramite il
Sacro corpo
sono spawnatissimo
i pensieri
Come si riescono sul controller Ma
[__] Scusate raga
Questo gioco che mi vuole male sono già
una partita
sembra un po' mio zio l'orzader comunque
in qualche modo tocca molti più capelli
come è
fatto lei
È giunta l'ora
l'agnello si unisca a noi no che lui sia
Benedetto dalla vostra Misericordia
[Musica]
Ada sarai mica tu Nice c'è qualcuno che
mi aiuta e sto cazzo di gioco
incredibile
Brava zia Brava brava Mi sei piaciuta
Che cazzo è bravissima quanto forte ma
quanto forte strategia
quindi dubito
dubito che io possa fare qualcosa tipo
attaccare gente così
a minchia me la devo portare in braccio
Madonna che giocata ha fatto la zia raga
che giocata ha fatto la zia che cazzo è
sono io che è il virus che fa che fa
effetto Meno male che siamo arrivati
tutto sto casino l'hai fatto dietro al
laboratorio sei un deficiente Sadler ce
l'hai fatto qua dietro c'è letteralmente
pirla atomico Vabbè cazzo
è proprio il virus
vai vai vai vai vai vai Meno male che
siamo qua dietro se no era finito
fai ancora Resistenza zitto
dai dai dai dai dai dai Oh merda che
cazzo è
[Musica]
è pieno di gente scusate devo passare ma
mi attaccano
non sono veramente qua Ah ok Minchia
Meno male
Madonna che momento assurdo
Sono caduto è cascato Dai
non mi piace la scheda sei morto e ho
perso no
Sì ma il laboratorio qualcuno mi deve
fare qualcosa eh perché se arrivo io non
è che non mi sento nelle condizioni di
fare cose strane
Ecco la si è arrivati alla porta apri
apri apri
Luis Miky È incredibile
se esco
Mannaggia e mo Ah devo ficcarla là fai
prima tu e poi faccio io
diversamente
come fai a esserci un laboratorio qua
dentro Comunque dopo tutto il casino che
ho fatto
ficcala
Cioè nel senso di Mettila sulla faccia
te l'ho detto Ti porterò dai veloci Non
parlate qua State morendo tutte e due
e basta schiacciare un tasto per fare
l'operazione
vai
Ma manco l'anestesia l'hai fatto
[Musica]
mai
Beh sicuramente sta meglio è morta
praticamente
tutto ok ce l'ho fatta è morta Non è che
è morta davvero Sto stronzo Ashley devi
fare la stessa cosa a me prima che muoia
sto morendo dovresti tipo muoverti hai
finito il capitolo
e quindi
Ashley
avrà fatto L'ha fatto anche lei a me
perfetto brava la zia Stavo morendo
quindi non ce l'abbiamo più
l'hai fatto tu Eh beh ha fatto Topo
Gigio lì
Brava hai schiacciato Invio Sei
bravissimo
è una mappa
Sì l'ho trovata
penso che ci sia una via d'uscita di
e siamo una squadra vero Continua così e
perderò il lavoro
Non ti crede nessuno ti crede neanche
lei secondo me
molto bene
rimuovere i parassiti è merito di lui è
stato veramente bravo
Europe lavorati Six Dream Team
bellissima
Sono convinto ma si può uscire di qua da
dove siamo entrati sì
Allora questa è la stanza con 2000
persone che non c'erano Va bene vai su
la zia scusa
tipo
va bene
dove cazzo è l'uscita Ah lì Ok va bene
Allora andiamo andiamo ma in realtà sono
stato meglio nella mia vita
vabbè come dici tu comunque incredibile
che le risposte sono sempre simili ok
secondo me ci sia Ah siamo nella stanza
di prima eh l'ho visto
sono sicuro di sì
non è una che si rende facilmente
Sì sono innamorato di lei non rompermi
il cazzo oh ah no vabbè di nuovo questi
Porca [__] io lo Striker ancora non
l'ho usato in tutto questo Madonna ma
che Rosa c'ha sto fucile a pompa
maledetta la vita e che ha inventato
sticazzo di cose
esci
ma adesso gli è rimasta fuori là ne hai
fregato niente brava a lei non gliene
frega un cazzo di sti cosi passa
attraverso praticamente c'è il
mercantone c'è il mercantone Attenzione
attenzione aspetta che qua lingotto
d'oro Oh minchia un'ora che non vedo
mercanti vediamo se c'è il mercato è uno
solo però Vabbè Allora fatemi capire un
attimo questo messo a proiettili e
munizioni carabina Madonna quanta roba
c'ho a riparazione Innanzitutto posso
vendere robe e c'è un illuminato schiavi
di Luis mi serve più questo qua perfetto
posso mettere anche le robe nel
bracciale Scusate un attimo
Ok incastona gemme 1 e 2 sono stato
bravissimo Comunque guarda che roba
ha detto Milanese è diventato così
allora potenza direi di aumentare la
potenza dello Striker ragazzi a sto
punto mica almeno è potente almeno
abbiamo di nuovo un fucile a pompa
potente velocità di ricarica tre colpi
alla volta dai almeno almeno è diventato
potente come Anzi forse più di quello di
prima dai Let's go my boys carichiamo
tutto e Let's go si può andare qua
Maledetti strunzi l'hanno presa proprio
Che cazzo devo fare Vado spera di
attirarmi Eh mi sa che ce la fa anche
cioè come faceva Ciao amica qua
siamo mica dei Maledetti Sì sì Tu stai
qua non fare un cazzo
Arrivederci bellissimo quando sta
indietro Meno male perché so che non
devo prendermi cura di questa qua
[Musica]
non puoi sparare potevi farlo anche dove
eri prima Dominick è morta è caduta l'82
metri morta
e i settini
ancora Sto stronzo ahia
Minchia si è svegliata Madonna
spider-man spider-man veramente
[Musica]
dubito che li stiate facendo qualcosa
ragazzi però vabbè
ma anche erotico
[Musica]
del sangue corpo umano Ah ma la fai tu
finale a merda merda
pensavo scappasse No no è una Fight
Tony Room merda Madonna che schifo
Ada fai qualcosa tipo che ne so
fino
la soluzione
a Facci Ro cazz
Minchia che grosso è Ada fai tu no se
n'è andata
Minchia Ragazzi mi sa che non
E vabbè E proviamo Madonna che forte è
il momento di utilizzare tutti i colpi
della Magnum Quindi se questa è la fai
finale bravo Mi sono fatto i complimenti
da solo attenzione
aspetta
perfetto perfetto gli ho levato già
tantissimo ragazzi eh Secondo me
Oh merda Ahia che male
meno male che ho riparato la
Wow
È terribile gigante ragazzi Posso
lanciarti anche le granate ti fai
qualcosa
Porca [__] che male che mi fa
ok
Meno male lo schivato
e mi sta saltando in faccia no Ok
perfetto vai vai vai vai
non l'ho preso l'ho preso dai
che cazzo arriva No Porca vacca
che cazzo succede
Minchia raga Sono tantissimi
Beh abbiamo trovato un'utilità per lo
Striker almeno Madonna che male non mi
ha preso non so come aspetta
No vabbè ragazzi terribile e gigantesco
Madonna che male L'ha ammazzato lui un
insetto Va bene mi sa che mi devo curare
Ma ragazzi non ho così tante Cure
comunque eh la vita l'ho ammazzata alla
fine del gioco Sono stato bravissimo È
solo che mi conviene Secondo me usare
perché sono troppi sti cosi Mannaggia a
chi li ha fatti
perfetto
Bravissima sono fortissimo
Oh lo sai che era fortissimo perché non
l'ho usato prima cazzo era fortissimo
minchia lo Striker devo ammazzarmi non
quell'altra arma di merda
aspetta
ok
Ok più o meno
Minchia che male non ho fatto niente
Allora ragazzi è difficilissimo che non
sta per poi io con la mia Mira di merda
Eh vabbè
va bene
E che cazzo
Ok Bravissimo
Magnum No no perché ancora non ha perso
quello dietro Ok perfetto Adesso l'ha
perso Vai Magnum
e non ci passo Porca [__]
Eh non l'avrei voluto fare così avrei
voluto farlo con la magnum gli avrei
dato molto di più ragazzi
porca merda e non ci passavo più
[__] ma dimmi te o
Comunque secondo me è più utile il
telescopico ragazzi non lo so Oddio non
lo so forse è meglio questo forse è
meglio questo che il telescopico Non lo
so raga
che male
ok
Ok
veloce veloce veloce
perfetto
bravissimo Madonna cosa ho fatto
vai di Magnum vai di Magnum
perfetto gli ho fatto un danno pazze E
bravo
No non lo so se ho vinto Ho vinto
ragazzi la magnum che fa assaggiare il
suo calibro anche al boss finale Madonna
mia
è morto
stavo scherzando Era stavo Ma io lo
sapevo scherzavo
adesso
effettivamente c'è ancora un po' di
colpi di Magnum mentre possiamo usare
via c'ha due fasi il boss finale se non
trefort Speriamo due
Porca [__]
Minchia quanto cazzo
Credo che questa sia la fase finale non
lo so
ma devo mirare al coso al centro che non
ho capito Devo migliorare le cose
ma sto mirando al coso giusto secondo me
non è così giusto quello eh
ha funzionato
lanciarazzi speciale acchiappalo
Madonna ragazzi che che
botta pazzesca gli ho dato io
Ma la tipa dove l'ha presa lanciarazzi
speciale se posso chiedere
c'è un'altra fase Spero di no è morto
Wow Madonna fighissimo penso sia morto
maronna ragazzi
Grazie
del lanciarazzilico
tranquillo ci starò attenta
È ora di andare
vieni Beh sarebbe utile ma Ashley
le nostre strade si separano
capisco
Madonna che gnocca ragazzi l'ho detto
per tutto il gioco ma è così l'acero
Ashley dove è saltato tutto in aria eh
Comunque volevo solo dire quello
cos'è
perché mi hai dato una chiave con un
orsacchiotto
alla prossima Lion Arrivederci Grazie di
tutto Ah non sei esplosa Peccato perché
ci speravo un attimino
dove sta andando chi lo sa non capisco
perché se n'è andata
ma dobbiamo scappare nel mentre Ah
quindi quella è una chiave tipo di una
barca o di un elicottero penso che
l'elicottero si accenderà la chiave
Credo di no mi sarà una barca a due
minuti ciò fuggire all'Isola posso
ancora utilizzare lo Striker e ho due
C'ho due minuti di tempo un cazzo
proprio vai Vieni Ashley Ah fammi sapere
la partita prima perché questa qua
pianta verde Ah quindi non è finito
porca [__]
Eh non me lo ricordavo Ragazzi purtroppo
non mi ricordo ci ho giocato troppo
tempo fa ho due colpi di Striker che
comunque alla fine ha fatto la
differenza anche lo Striker Meno male
raga ero convinto di aver buttato tutto
Eh speriamo
mo arriva arriverà la Madonna qua
Ma c'è Orca [__] salta
sono le miniere di Moria queste
un minuto e 45 Porca [__]
[__] a soreta è morto non è morto
ho finito i colpi del fucile non ce li
ho più
Non lo so ma questa la regalo
[Musica]
Ah non possono più combattere non posso
più fare niente se non c'hanno l'orsetto
E va bene allora che non li cago neanche
perché se l'orsadler è morto Muoiono
tutti Ah già giusto perché lui che li
comandava Va bene allora ho capito figo
ce l'abbiamo fatta
è una moto d'acqua questa qua è la
chiave della moto d'acqua adesso
chiave della moto era una moto d'acqua
ancora devo fare ancora cose ma porca
[__]
accelera Muoviti posso incontrare gente
anche qua sotto mi sembra un po'
eccessivo Porca [__]
bellissima che è diventato GTA V va bene
Devo schiva schiva tutto stia tutto
schivalo
manca un minuto
E vabbè non è che posso fare tutto
attenzione bravissimo
[__] quanto cazzo va sta moto d'acqua
hai 3.000 all'ora ci fa cos'è Ciao bravo
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo
bravo bravo lo zio come se la destreggia
Madonna mi sono cagato in mano
ce l'abbiamo fatta Non è vero Non lo so
dove vado Ah ci stiamo facendo tutta la
facilità la facility di prima in acqua
va bene
va bene va bene va bene va bene va bene
va bene che effetti speciali cazzo
Michael Bay
sta crollando tutto
tranne dove dobbiamo passare noi
giustamente con 40 secondi ragazzi non
so se ce la faccio Eh spero di sì perché
sono stretto proprio Ecco la vedo
l'uscita perfetto
30 secondi ce la faccio
ce la fa
[Musica]
proprio Lui proprio lui
Minchia tutta tutta tutta [__] è
andato là
ho fatto saltare tutto
[Musica]
credo che siano morti tutti
indipendentemente da Lord Sandler
proprio
cazzo lei è contenta all'acquapark
Missione compiuta giusto dai
teoricamente dobbiamo tornare in America
con la moto d'acqua secondo me è un po'
difficile
Grazie per avermi salvata Prego di
niente
potrei
raccomandarti a mio padre
assumerti come mi ascolta Se ti
interessa
non ti serve
hai dimostrato di sapersi
[Musica]
andiamo
si torna a casa
adesso
[Musica]
Sì sì allora dove sei finito rispondi
Grazie dell'aiuto ragazzi No veramente
senza di voi non sarei qua
dall'inizio del gioco praticamente
incredibile
signori residenti vol 4 remake Ma che
bello che è stato Ma che bel gioco ma
poi ragazzi Scusatemi è durato
tantissimo molto più degli altri
Resident Evil 2 remake il 3 remake
duravano la metà praticamente più o meno
forse anche meno della metà non so
quante ore di gioco sarà Anzi sono
curioso di vedere quante ore di gioco
fatto credo 15 più o meno 15 ore di
gioco Ragazzi comunque vedere le
registrazioni che ho fatto quindi
secondo me cioè è tanta roba Ci hanno
fatto un remake della madonna e non sono
stato neanche a fare tutte le secondarie
perché non può ne ho fatte ma non le ho
fatte tutte 15 ore di gioco per aver
fatto quasi solo la storia principale un
po' poco di più quindi tanta roba
Complimenti Bellissimo Per adesso il
miglior remake di Resident Evo Secondo
me tutto bellissimo Peccato che non ho
sentito la voce originale del mercante
che faceva Wow fuori io poi dobbiamo
salire in italiano però era anche figo
in italiano Ehm mi sono molto divertito
Spero anche voi non c'è un finale
segreto vero
tipo roba dopo i sottotitoli cioè lo
sapevo Cioè non lo sapevo in realtà
Che cazzo è
Adam pirla
ho recuperato l'ambra
eccellente
solo una domanda che cosa ha intenzione
di farci avendo su eBay
incento daranno la vita affinché una
persona sopravviva
Io sto solo accelerando questo fenomeno
quindi parliamo di milioni di vittime
miliardi bene
[Applauso]
cambiamo rotta subito ma non si è fatta
comprare la zia
[Musica]
Che cazzo è Ah siamo e Lion con Ashley
Ma dove stiamo andando raga con la moto
d'acqua
in America proprio
Quindi alla fine non glielo porta
non glielo porterà Ma chi era western
Oh
bellissimo Vabbè Questa è la finale dopo
i crediti signori come detto prima Spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto come al
solito vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento e un mi piace
nella descrizione noi ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video e come sempre bella
ragazzi
[Musica]